that's not the plan
so did you go to high school in the
valley
or did you guys meet at the same school
or so I went to like five different high
schools of course you did I went to a
lot of different high schools in search
of like football you know so yeah
because I mean though right yeah so
whichever school had like
a position for me and they had they had
a little bit of recruitment coming in I
would [__] with them you know so I went
to
I went to Belgium and Burbank to private
school I went to Valencia High School my
freshman year for like two months and
like by Santa Clarita yeah Santa Clara I
went to Valencia High School for two
months left
went to Belgium for like a semester left
then I went to um Golden Valley I like
the Golden Valley because it was more
diverse really diverse that's for sure
that's where I met her it's really like
where's that at it's in Santa Clarita so
it's a lot of um
it's just diverse yeah like all the
others bad kids get sent there yeah I
almost bought a house out there yeah so
I went to Golden Valley right then I
went to I tried out for Washington High
School in the hood
not my hood but like just in the battery
um what other school what was it uh
[__] I was packed I tried it for nerd
bomb for long for a little bit
then I end up going to our leader yeah I
like that was that the prom that you
guys
okay so I went to our leader she did all
those I went back to Golden Valley like
my senior year like I went to like five
different high schools every year every
semester I was at a different High
School like what how old were you when
you had your six-year-old
I was eight I had was just about to turn
18. so this was like senior year well I
had graduated and my birthday was later
that year so I graduated and that's
probably when like it happened when you
guys are in the same grade or were you
younger I'm one year younger okay so
freshman was sophomore when you were
pregnant was he at no no Fayetteville
playing football no no it's like when he
just came back okay because he he left
right came back and then he was just
because he was kind of just ripping and
running and then I really wasn't on my
[__] like what's ripping and running
mean
and
um no we was just doing our [__] we was
just getting it how we could
I was a sophomore she was a freshman
um
in PE class we hit it off
then I started switching schools again
and we just stayed in contact she used
to come to my house every day after
school take the bus and everything
yeah she takes a hell of a bus the bus
is so crazy no but she he lived not
close it wasn't like it was crazy yeah
it was just like one up the hill like it
wasn't like 100 miles every day after
school we go to different schools and
[__] she got around every day after
school then go home when like it's
getting too late you know
all the way up until I graduated boom
I graduated I went to Fayetteville so
when I graduated went to Fayetteville
she was a senior
no I was taking two extra classes one in
the morning and one after school all the
seniors left at 12. no no I forgot about
that just so you can graduate wait look
no no to go to the school I didn't even
know cap I was behind on credits because
I would I would show up late or I would
just ditch right not show up because I
was just [__] around and so then my
senior year they were like you can
graduate obviously but if you want to
get a if you want to get to where he's
at you have to do this this and that
which was a class before everyone
started in a class after after so
everyone was coming at eight leaving at
12. I'm showing up at seven leaving at
one yeah so I was just like trying to
get into school I just wanted to I
wanted to be able to just get and go
because my mom I had a single mom I
wanted to get to the college I was at
just a video I had a single mom so I
wasn't like oh I I got someone that can
just sign this check off like and it'd
be cool like no I had a single mom
working a full-time job like what she
wasn't even paid for so this is like
really like a high school
because she left me
but why did I leave you he's playing
stupid okay look okay look Christian got
Jonathan's [__] title right here and
then she was like oh hell no this she
was pregnant at the time she was like oh
hell no I'm out of here [__] she stole
my car no it wasn't just that it was so
cat bro okay okay she got like three
tattoos it wasn't even just that no no
let me tell him
that's about you baby it is about me
explain okay because this is what
happens
don't do that okay so I left because I
was living at his house me and this uh
me and our son and then he had his mom
her husband always all living in one
house but we was all like exchanging
days at the restaurant right when I had
my restaurant yeah I had a whole family
House
Restaurant
yeah good I'm telling him stories okay
so I'm saying so we had the restaurant
that me and her got into it yeah you and
Mom yes okay but me and her been around
each other so long that it's like I've
got into it my own birth mom that we was
gonna get over it but I just needed it I
needed to Stand My Ground because that
was crazy you know what I mean so then
I'm telling him and he's not coming home
every night this is not the this is if
you please if anyone's out there
thinking he's coming home every night
he's not okay he's so not
it doesn't matter how he makes it seem
like this he's not coming
we got to get that third I gotta be I
got to be bootlegs
you think sometimes to get bootleg out
there on the streets Kev you feel me um
all right go ahead anyway continue she
looks disgusted I'm disgusting but this
is not even cute like so so essentially
he's not coming home every night
continue you get into it anyway he's not
coming home every night and I'm pregnant
I'm pregnant as [__] throwing up in the
morning like oh you're not here in the
morning to hear me throw up right oh I'm
sorry I'm gonna do this and I already
have one and I don't even know what's
going on yeah and we just I just got
into it your mom she across the way
right I don't in the same house I'm so
mad you're not around right referee me
and your mom help me do something either
you eat are you coming home or or like
we got to figure out a living situation
for this or a restaurant situation for
this like bro she coming this day I'm
coming that day what are we doing
because that was so not happening so
then you leave them so then I'm like you
don't come home in the next 30 minutes
I'm out I already have my bag sitting at
the end of the bed like this and you had
to clock around already I said you're
not here in the next 30 minutes I'm out
no he was out he I don't even think he
was away it was like seven it was so
early because I was like my mind is sad
asleep all night I said probably my head
Christian at the time honestly I don't
know because
like I don't I don't know it could have
been anybody because she might have not
been around well he did bring up the
tattoos I gotta ask you from somebody
who you guys are high school sweethearts
you have two children together yeah you
see Krishan
she obviously blows up she's a
personality but she gets
father tattooed on her neck so all that
happened when I was pregnant so it kind
of to me was like oh y'all playing with
me like and and your your hormones are
going crazy well that's why I left them
to begin with so I was pregnant he's not
coming home he's acting a fool he's not
doing the most so I just left I'm going
through a lot I took his car I took his
car and I just went to my mom's
what you gonna do now right now I'm
saying this this is and that now what
he's like oh you're crazy whatever we're
gonna have our gender reveal go to the
gender reveal
it's not happening the way it was
supposed to happen like no so look let
me let okay let me chime in no okay so
when she leave me I'm like come back you
know please come back I tell her for
like a week I probably that whole a week
she's been going I probably hit her like
three times like come on come back you
ain't gotta do this right
I so did after a week she like uh uh
I've been looking at this place I'm
gonna go do this I'm gonna go do that I
was that mad oh my damn all right
so then right that's how I got stuck
with rock cause I'm all right
you come uh you in the game now you're
in the game now [__] come on
the game come on like you're in you're
in I'm a high school I'm a high school
football coach you feel me like him yeah
that's how I'm out here coaching
Mighty Mites okay family junior [__]
I'm trying to find
perfect
Cheers Cheers Cheers come on babe cheers
I'm not drinking this oh wait we got to
plug this in here okay you don't need a
drink let me help you out here all right
are we cheers in Cheers Cheers guys so
that soda by the way guys he has orange
soda in the cup
I'm like all right she left me like she
she like on her own [__] I'm gonna get
my own place I wanted to be in my name
I'm going to pay them because you was
playing around
baby I'll help you
you want to get a place I put it in my
name right and I did it I'll pay the
bills no [__] I wanted to be in my name
you feel me mommy got her piece the name
is in my lease I'm like damn you good
come on I did say that she sent me that
I did say that she hit you with the bar
I did hit him with the bar she was like
my name is on the lease mommy got her
piece I was like damn that's okay she
showed you up no but you know what you
you know you know he was like all right
Rock You In the game come on like okay
okay let's be let me let me I have to
take a stance here okay go ahead I'm
somebody who has children
I can listen a pregnant woman yeah no I
know they get I was four months pregnant
listen you're going through a lunatic he
saw what I was pregnant than that no it
was four months pregnant we just found
out what it was but listen I was gonna
say Obviously in like professional I'm a
looney you're out doing what you're
doing there's this girl getting
Jonathan's [__] attack exactly
and she's carrying your child and she
has your other kid and your mom and he
said oh I mean I didn't do that like
he's like the day one
and so for me I'm watching all this and
just from like somebody who is just not
even not even looking at it from
somebody who knows you just looking at
I'm like okay obviously Christian Rock's
good for business yeah right that's what
it started out as though I never wanted
as far too
she started getting the tattoos on her
own
listen after her first tattoos her first
tattoos I said I don't think you should
be doing this kind of appropriate it
makes you look like yeah you're intimate
and it's less business
and she just wasn't listening well as I
say did it spiral out of control so much
that you guys were
publicly so associated with with each
other that it kind of was like a forced
because listen when you got like she got
on his blue faces girlfriend well when
y'all came to the studio last time I
interviewed both of you guys
um it was you could cut the tension
between y'all with a knife yeah no it's
kind of like it's kind of like
she got on the blueface's boyfriend
girlfriend I mean you wouldn't have a
boyfriend obviously I
don't face his girlfriend but it's like
she kind of like
used that and then when it wasn't usable
she kind of used that and then when it
wasn't usable she kind of like all right
let me
let me let me go this way you know like
I said I'm not gonna fire are you hoping
she gets the tattoos removed no I mean I
really don't care for me personally
tattoos are a part of time history you
know trials and tribulations and I feel
like I'm a part of her time his three
trials and tribulation so
is there any more business for y'all to
do together
man I'm always interested in business
I'm always open to business but like I
said earlier once you do business
without me it's none of my business and
the relationship aspect of YouTube is
done
I mean she has my if she has my child
I'm gonna no no you guys are gonna have
a relationship I just mean in terms of
like you guys being intimate you guys
being you know any sort of uh
are you are you done clapping Christian
Rock's cheeks at this point in your life
personally
I don't think that
I think that she she might need to be
humbled something might need to occur
for her to
realize like hey
all these people all year round because
of who I am today and not who I was
three years ago
and it's just a humbling experience you
know all right I'm just like that I saw
I saw she go with the club and I was
just like damn like well that was
recently yeah like two days ago
like hey they keep deleting my Ig here's
10 grand go sit down like I don't want
myself to get miscarriage trust me I
will pay for her to sit down but
she's into the attention she likes
people walking up to her she likes the
camera she likes the attention so it's
like I can't fight with her on that you
feel me like if you get more of a
feeling of people saying hey hey then
you get off being home and and enjoying
having a home to be at and and having
you know your own then I'm not gonna
fight with you on that bro because